quantum theory is known to be
incomplete here we provide a fresh
approach to light and the atom
that gives theorists a perspective they
can integrate
into their research
what if we took a new look at the
particles and transverse wave models of
light
as well as at the ubiquitous planetary
atom with which we
typically simulate phenomena such as
quantum jump
ionization and electricity
what if we were to assume that light is
mediated rather
by a physical entity that has the
architecture of a rope
a pair of anti-parallel twine threads
under this proposal light consists of
bi-directional torsions propagating
along a dna-like structure
now torsion is one of the fastest things
you can imagine
and explains the cause behind the
fantastic speed of light
what induces the rope to torque
in the course of quantum jumping a
discrete electron
is said to jump back and forth between
energy levels
for no apparent reason
let's replace this unexplained behavior
with a physical mechanism mediated by an
atom
weaved by the same threads that
constitute the electromagnetic
rope
the threads that comprise the rope fork
out at the boundary of the electron
membrane and one of them extends
straight to the center of the atom
ropes extending from every atom in
existence
converge upon our atom and each donates
one thread to construct the proton star
the other thread coils around and builds
the electron shell
that encapsulates the proton star
it is thus that we replace the abstract
orbital
with a physical membrane that expands
and contracts
while doing so it torques the rope
the atom is a tiny heart pumping
bi-directional
three-dimensional torsion waves to every
atom in the universe the proposal is
that all
atoms are physically bound to each other
via torquing ropes
the underlying assumption is that there
is a single closed loop thread
that weaves all atoms and forms the
ropes
that interconnect them
[Music]
you